c'est que la méthode là est bonne le
chemin prend Emmanuel Macron et le bon
chemin alors il est incontournable il
faudra juger sur pièce c'est à dire que
il faudra voir si dans ce qu'il annonce
il y a effectivement les bons éléments
et ensuite il faudra voir surtout s'ils
sont mis en œuvre alors je vais vous
donner un exemple aujourd'hui on dit il
serait souhaitable qu'on arrive à
s'organiser avec moins de voitures en
fait même si on est électrifie des
voitures là aujourd'hui 40 millions de
voitures particulières en France même si
on électrifie tout ce qu'on peut
électrifier on n'aura jamais 40 millions
de véhicules d'une tonne et demi
électrique en France ça passe pas au
niveau du réseau ça passe pas au niveau
des matériaux parce que tous les autres
vont faire vouloir faire paraître etc
donc il serait bon de s'organiser avec
moins de voitures mais dans le même
temps qu'on dit ça on continue à
rajouter des infrastructures routières
je prends l'exemple de la 69 par exemple
en Occitanie on peut se poser la
question de la pertinence quel que soit
le service que ça va rendre à court
terme est-ce que c'est vraiment
pertinent de s'organiser avec une
infrastructure qui va durer un siècle
dans un monde dans lequel on cherche à
faire en sorte qu'on soit moins
dépendant de la voiture oui bon donc ce
genre de choses c'est c'est il y a
d'abord la planification c'est-à-dire le
schéma d'ensemble et puis ensuite quand
on passe à l'acte il y a un milliard de
problèmes concrets techniques à régler
vous dites ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a un décalage entre des
objectifs affichés et des actes
évidemment je vais vous en prendre un
autre il y a eu l'interdiction
soi-disant des vols intérieurs en fait
trois lignes intérieures dans ce pays
mais dans le même temps on s'est
félicité du regain du tourisme l'été
dernier du tourisme international
notamment et à ce que je sache les
Japonais et les Américains viennent pas
qui avec de mer donc on a un décalage
aujourd'hui entre les discours et les
actes effectivement quand on regarde en
pratique et c'est toute la difficulté
[Musique]